making the first John wick did you think
that you would be here talking about
John wick chapter two I did not but I
was hoping I really loved the underworld
right there's like there's like the real
world and there's like meta you know the
world of the assassins and so we created
this two continental and when you learn
about the high table but we opened up
that world and and then they action you
know we could take the action to another
level because I had the experience of
the first one so I could I could advance
a little bit obviously bringing Lorenson
and having the matrix reunion those
winds are going to be even more no it's
not a matrix reunion I mean it's for the
fans who liked it though they're like oh
my god waiting to see you guys together
again yeah what is it yeah now he's
really excited work with Lauren again
and he's magnificent in a legend and you
know the role that he decided to play
was written for him so I'm the Bowery
King and just like there's a high table
there's a low table so I'm sort of the
king at the low table and he has to come
to me for help and it's like boom they
pulled up yeah the curtain back and
there's yet another layer to this world
what was it about this world that made
you say yes I want to be a part of the
world of John link everything everything
about this world made me want to say yes
in particular the professionalism the
politeness and the affection that all
these people had seemed to have for one
yeah you've got it up the badassery so
what are your characters bring to the
table that you feel like really upset
auntie Cathy and is like someone who
rivals John Wiccan and skill level and
though that you know they are going at
each other at a certain point they both
have a respect and reverence for each
other and that you know in that book
that's because they both fought at that
level yeah in the first one they were
trying to eliminate John wick by getting
as many people together to sort of
ambush him to outnumber him which didn't
work use your skills and this sort of
feels like they've grabbed the best of
the best where I came from and with my
skill set that you know and I kind of
take the whole Silent Assassin thing to
a new level yeah and then you've got
Cathy and character and and we're all
like kind of on par with the same skill
set we were all like really well matched
yeah and the Continental has two rules
which is honor the marker and
no business on the ground if you guys
could add a rule what would it be
they should late let you have your pets
in your room you know Jonathan leave the
dog at the counter and then a seem happy
they had lower dog just sitting there
but I was like like when it's my goal to
talk at night about my dog in the bed
with me you know I think if you had a
friend or someone close to you kill you
should get a free night they don't use
your coin like it was justifiable if you
could add a rule what would you add no
no rule guy
[Music]
you